are you a doomsday prepper
i hear that terminology all the time i
see those commercials but this is what
that sounds like is that would you
categorize yourself as that
i would categorize myself as uh
as uh uh as the remnant
of the great generation
you know that's one of the things uh you
know i find it particularly annoying you
know modern culture
condemns preparedness now by mocking it
and calling people doomsday preppers
okay overly paranoid you know my my
mother and father but that's what they
call themselves though
well i don't call myself that uh you
know i call myself an american i call
myself a person who
has the character profile that this
country was originally founded
by the founders
people who believe in rugged
individualism and self-sufficiency and
are jealous of their freedom
uh and don't believe in
in in trusting the government to take
care of all of our needs which is where
we have become now uh those who call me
at doomsday prepper i would say those
who don't prepare are sheep
uh you know the kind of mentality that
the founders
well this country wasn't designed for
sheep it was designed for eagles it was
designed for people who believed in
freedom and believed in self-sufficiency
and not taking handouts you know my my
father's generation
the generation that lived through the
great depression and survived world war
ii they had never heard of emp
uh all of those people all virtually all
of them
would be doomsday preppers because they
didn't believe in trusting the
government to take care of them they had
seen government fail and war and peace
that seen it fail in the great
depression that seen it fail with the
outbreak of world war ii
they knew
my father and my uncle joe for example
who fought in world war ii you know
again against the nazis my father was a
sergeant my uncle joe had been a private
they knew that world war ii was not won
by franklin roosevelt and general george
patton world war ii was won by a
tough guys like them you know who went
up against nazi tanks that were better
than ours
better armed and better led
uh
germans and defeated them that was their
guts and blood that won world war ii and
so you know uh they were not uh you know
uh
uh willing to trust in government they'd
seen government fail in peace during the
great depression
and in war and they're the ones that got
us through world war ii and that
attitude persisted afterwards that's why
in the 1950s so many americans were
digging bomb shelters you know we laugh
at that today and seem to mock it today
but they were really concerned the
government screw up again and would have
a nuclear war and they wanted to survive
and make sure their family would survive
you know we lived on a quarter acre and
uh you know we had
orchards uh you know uh apple trees a
garden my mother was constantly canning
food might they had never heard of emp
but they were concerned that there would
be some disaster maybe an atomic was
that more common back then than today do
you think that was more of a common oh
absolutely etiquette
it was a common value of all americans
beginning with the founding of this
country because those virtues that we're
talking about here the self-sufficiency
the rugged individualism the pride it
was a point of pride that you wanted to
be able to take care of your own family
and not depend on a neighbor and
certainly not depend on a church or a
government to take care of you you
wanted to be able to take care of your
neighbors yourself
i i have a slight
and pushback if you if i may sure
there's something you talk about is
something that's great in theory but
that's great in practice
with you a hundred percent on rugged
individualism taking care of yourself
taking care of your family being
self-sufficient limited government a
thousand percent on the same page
however i also am a personal finance
expert i also know that 80 of americans
are living paycheck to paycheck i
understand that people are you know have
budgets i understand that inflation is
at eight percent it's going all-time
high
gas is expensive um cost of living is
expensive so if i'm
all right all right dr price i'm with
you i'm ready to go get a farm in
virginia or a place in the everglades or
something
how do you
take that theory and put it into
practice if you're making 50 grand a
year or you're making 100 grand a year
or even if you're a multi-millionaire
what percentage of your budget should
you be putting towards getting a
a bunker or something like that because
it's great in theory amazing of course
everyone should have a bunker but who's
actually doing it and that's what i'm
grappling with right now about three
percent of the population is actually
doing it right now and that's a shame
you know because of what it reflects
this passing of
what we would call the pioneer values
the values that we're talking about here
are what made america great and free in
the first place and most americans up
until my father's generation the great
generation
had those values and were prepared and
they weren't making a hundred thousand a
year my father was making less than
fifty thousand a year but they were
prepared for anything and uh you know
ever heard of a victory garden i mean
that was very common during world war ii
and uh and people made them on their on
their own uh i remember in my uncle joe
he owned a bar down in utica new york
and he had a tiny little backyard i mean
it wasn't
you know it was the size of a living
room what is a victory garden it's a
it's a it's a it's a cultivated
wikipedia is a war garden or food
gardens for defense
or vegetable where vegetables uh
vegetables fruit and herbal guns are
planted at private residences and public
parks united states uk canada
interesting yeah in world war ii almost
everybody had a victory guard and they
and they would grow their own food
everybody anybody that's in a time where
people were living in the suburbs you
had all this land now majority of
americans are in new york city in l.a in
chicago downtown miami my uncle joe
there's living in places like this my
uncle joe was living in the middle of
utica new york okay and as i was
explaining to you uh the the backyard
behind his bar was maybe the size of a
living room where's utica new york
though utica new york cincinnati upstate
new york okay so what happens if i lived
in new york city you know
well if you live in new york city you do
you can you might want to think about uh
do you have friends who live in the
country here's what i would if i can
jump in here here's what i have water
what percentage of america do you think
needs to own a life insurance policy i
mean anyone with kids or a business okay
only 54 do 46 don't right yeah some of
them can't do it some of them cannot do
it right okay what percentage of rich
people here live on the water
there's people that are waterfront
property mostly a lot of these guys are
your friends okay they got houses in
miami whatever you know
beachfront intercoastal whatever maybe
okay great uh
those guys are probably not gonna have a
nuclear you know
bomb shelter with victory gardens in the
backyard where they're living at but
when a hurricane happens what do they do
what happens when hurricane happens
they've got uh well either they leave
town okay what happened i've never been
part of a hurricane inside but the other
day the weather was pretty crazy what
happened but when a hurricane happens
what do most people do in florida they
put up their shutters and they just
buckle down or some of them drive up
right they get out of dodge okay they
get out of dodge so this isn't for a
hundred percent of people
the way i'm processing this
it's not for 100 of people and to be
honest with you it lets you say you
don't have a lot of money as a family
what i would do it in some like this to
prepare for it
is i would have the family
collectively decide to get one look
you're you're the religion your faith is
what you're you're you grew up judaism
right i'm a christian right i don't know
what you're uh
what you grew up with yourself
i grew up around a lot of mormons
i was in an insurance company lots of
guys there were more
lds yeah
and
one of the things that was very
fascinating about the church of
mormonism okay
is they prepared their people a lot i
don't know how it is with judaism
but there's nobody more suspicious than
paranoid than jews okay so then just
know that but but then but then but how
far do they take that because at mormons
that i went with many of the people that
were leaders stake presidents all this
other stuff
they had in their homes they were ready
that was one of the things that was very
consistent this is in utah no not in
utah it wasn't lodi california it was in
you know l.a it was basements
they were fully prepared for that in
case i'm in atlanta like and i'm talking
like
in cummings georgia and not like you
know they were ready for something like
that and these are not people these are
people that are like hey
if something happens we're ready for it
this doesn't mean you go be to you know
a place that's very exotic and all this
other stuff it's just something you
build so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]